foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
relationships your mental health your
money everything I'm John deloney joined
by my good friend best-selling author
Rachel Cruz and we're taking your calls
on money and life whatever you got going
on Triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go out to
Kelly and I was going to say Louisville
but the Lewisville people came after me
that would have been a gem yeah so Kelly
in Louisville Kentucky what is up Kelly
how we doing
hi so we've got some mother-in-law drama
and we were hoping to get some good
advice on what we should do bring it on
got the you got the man of the hour
what's up okay what have you done we
have
so when my husband was in college his
mom took out Parent Plus loans and just
for simplicity's sake I'll make the
numbers even and easy to follow she took
about twenty five thousand dollars in
Parent Plus Loans
um come to find out about 20 000 of that
was refunded
um so for example if the student loan or
I'm sorry if the student account was
like 1500 she would take like a five
thousand dollar loan and get a 3 500
refund and that happened multiple times
throughout his time in college and over
the course of the four years
she had gotten about twenty thousand
dollars in refund so fast forward to now
she wants us to pay back the original
amount owed which was 25 even though she
was refunded over twenty thousand and
the refunds were never put back towards
the student loan she just did whatever
she did with them what does she say
about that does she admit to that
so when we asked her at first when my
husband asked her at first about the
refunds she said well I don't know what
happened to that money that was so long
ago I don't remember and then about
maybe a week or two later she went on
the website where all the payment like
the Nelnet website and said well if you
want to know where that money went over
the last seven years I've paid you know
x amount of dollars in interest so
that's where that money went oh no our
argument yeah so our argument is because
she's been making the loan payments
since he graduated so our argument was
that she had taken those refunds and
applied them back to the principal
balance at the time she would never have
to pay that much interest and it'd
probably be paid off by now so at this
point she wants the original amount
repaid even though out of that amount
twenty thousand dollars was refunded so
25 is what she's looking for 25 000 that
she won over four years she wants a
hundred back
so it was twenty five thousand dollars
total that she took out for my husband
and Parent Plus Loans but only five
thousand dollars went to school expenses
well yes so the agreement always was
that she that that he would pay it back
when he was making enough money so up
until the covet and everything hit and
they paused loan payments she was making
the the student loan payments well
he's recently just deployed and so we're
making all this good money so she wanted
us to pay back the loan like now like
time now and so at first our argument
was will they paused payments we're not
going to pay it well
um then we ended up pulling the bursar's
records like I said and we found that 20
000 so it's like we don't we all didn't
know about that y'all didn't know about
that until recently
no no we didn't know about that until
maybe a maybe two months ago or so when
she started saying she wanted us to pay
it back now because we're making the
good money which is you know fair so we
pulled the bursar's records and found
that 20 000 was refunded so now it's
like well hold on you want 25 even
though 20 000 was refunded and and that
was something that he never knew about
so so
long story short
she took out a five thousand dollar loan
to pay a parent plus loan to pay for his
school and they shook hands and said
I'll pay you back and then she took out
a twenty thousand dollar loan using his
school loans and spent it on God knows
what and now she wants you guys to pay
the full 25 back
so she took out so pretty much how it
worked to my understanding is every time
there was a bill due at the college
there it would say like your account
balance is fifteen hundred dollars and
again I'm just using simple numbers just
for to keep it easy let's say the
student Bill said you owe fifteen
hundred dollars on your account well she
would take out a loan for you know five
thousand and pay the pay the bill but
then the remainder of it would get
refunded back to her account that's what
I mean so she she took out a twenty
thousand dollar loan what went to
education was five thousand dollars
Yeah well yeah that's what I would
pretty much and here's how you have to
look at this
she has by her lack of integrity and I
don't want to talk bad about anybody's
mom or mother-in-law but this is we're
just calling a spade a spade
she has chosen to be a person who lacks
Integrity which means she has severed
the relationship
and she's turned this into a business
transaction that she's trying to duct
tape some weird morality to you said you
said you said
and
your husband her son did say
and so the ethical thing would have been
to do to take out a loan what they said
they were going to do take out a loan to
cover his educational expenses which
would have averaged out to I mean would
have come to a a total of five thousand
dollars and the rest of the money that
got refunded you can send that money
back it's simple it's a very simple
process to put it back give it back to
the school and say we don't want that
needed yeah and so she didn't do that
she had a slush fund of twenty thousand
dollars and now the Pipers the Piper's
got to be paid and so I if this isn't my
I always like to answer these what I
would do in this moment
I would sell what I have to sell I go
down to one car I would do whatever I
could to get five thousand dollars and
write that check and call it good and I
may even attach the school Bill to it
and and have it highlighted that's what
I was going to say is clear
documentation is possible to be able to
say here's where we feel good about this
because yes you I said I would pay back
the loan but I'm paying back the loan of
money that was used for my school not
this money that's drifted off into
mystery right land right I mean like if
he had taken that if he had taken some
of that money and paid for his living
expenses yeah then I would expect him to
pay it back but he didn't he didn't use
all 25 000 he used five thousand dollars
of it and there's a fancy word for this
it's called fraud
she defrauded the government she
basically yeah or she stole from your
son one of the two you can't do that
and by the way she happens all over the
place with parents taking parents out
and spending that money is there a lot
of
um like is she angry about it like
what's her like emotional bent towards
this I'm just curious
if she can be reasoned with like can she
be reasoned with
no not really
um I would say from what we've gathered
and and what she's told us so this isn't
completely skeptical but from what we've
gathered is that she was trying to
purchase a home and I I think again it's
a little skeptical but not completely we
think she's pretty like has an urgency
to get it paid off so that her credit is
in a better place to buy a home that's
why well she should have thought of that
one before she defrauded the government
and stole from her son here's the deal
there's no way this happens without a
fight or without her saying mean things
about you guys or whatever at the end of
the day she has chosen to be an
unethical mother to her son quite
honestly and it's really sad so the
fight has begun
um what you're gonna do is You're Gonna
Keep Your Head Held High you're gonna be
a person of dignity and respect you're
going to do what you said you're going
to do and you're moving on because this
relationship is separate
hate that video we'll be right back
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
we are back this is the Ramsay show
talking about money your mental and
emotional health your work whatever you
got going on in your life triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined by my good friend
Rachel Cruz lifewell life good yeah it
is going out with the sister-in-laws
this weekend it's a brave move yeah we
know I like them that's true I was
actually friends with my sister-in-law
before once and I dated oh so she's
coming down yeah we're hanging out for
the weekend that's very cool yep yep yep
um okay John one of the things I would
say things pushbacks that I always get
specifically on social media I'll kind
of like make it that umbrella
um of anything we teach anything any
money content that I put out there the
number one pushback that I always get is
when I tell couples to share bank
accounts
so when I talk about combining your
money being one all this I mean eight
people come out of the woodwork mad at
me and then I saw an Instagram reel of a
pretty well-known person We're not gonna
give him a shout out but he was saying
no you should have separate accounts and
then he got all this backlash probably
from Ramsey people I was like no it's
the worst advice you need one account so
there's all this conflicting advice out
there perspectives all of it but I mean
I stand pretty pretty strong on this I
remember us I think we were out at
Dave's we were having a conversation and
I remember thinking
so you'll share a bed
you will share genetics and make humans
make kids
you'll share
legal transactions like buying a house
and buying cars everything yeah but not
that seems like a strange place to draw
the line and I get it feels like it's
the pseudo safety right it's like people
like me who are kind of mini Preppers
who like I got my my I got mine over
here my beans stored up in the basement
like that's gonna protect you right
um
I honestly it's one of the few things
that I I outside of an abusive
relationship if you've had an abusive
past where somebody like I get wanting
to protect yours I get that
that's one of the few things Rachel I've
tried to wrap my head around and I just
can't I don't understand the the the the
hate you get for telling people you
gotta split up your banking I mean you
got to share your banking yeah because I
think one of the biggest motivators is
fear of divorce what right what if he
leaves what if you want to leave and you
don't you can't have any money I mean
it's a lot of that rhetoric that's part
of this there's that and then there's
this like independent
oh I have my own thing it feels good to
make my own money be responsible for
myself there's like an independent side
as well don't get married on both of
those because getting married is a
decision to not be independent anymore
but to create a new entity together yeah
right uh two becomes one like to create
a new path forward in the world that you
were once all by yourself and now we are
forever joined as a gang totally so talk
about that because I think there's one
element to me that you know people like
well we fight all the time when we share
accounts but when we've separated them
we don't fight anymore because we don't
have to talk about it I'm like that's
like saying well yeah you're a voice
you're literally avoiding the biggest
fight
unless I drink a whole lot and then I
just feel better right yes well that
works I guess until it doesn't that
avoidance I'm like yeah yeah on the
surface sure but then you're sweeping
under the real issues of why you don't
want to share an account and then do you
think that habits of oh we don't talk
about it we're gonna avoid it that that
seeps into other areas of marriage not
just money does it become a hat does it
become a I think and I think it's I
think it reveals
I am hanging on to either a tiny little
corner of this person I used to be I am
I've got a fantasy that I'm gonna oh I'm
it's gonna be me but we're just gonna be
married now I I think it is not going
all in and I think it I think that's
just one of those things that reveals it
because if somebody says
um I refuse to share a bed with the
person I just married people would be
like you're weird right I mean that just
doesn't make any sense right
um unless they snore a lot and then God
bless you go to another room yeah
but but like there's these other things
I'm not ever putting my spouse on my
card that's just weird right or my house
no that's right but this is the one that
we're all like yeah you go right so I
get it but here's the deal it's pseudo
autonomy it's not real yeah because if
you get divorced the the judge is going
to split it up right and it it's just
not real yes unless again
and you have to create an off-ramp yep
somebody it's kind of the last call
somebody else has already breached broke
in that relationship right and now
you're trying to stay alive that's a
different thing but if you're going all
in to be married
you've got to go all in yeah and then
I'm like I literally was thinking about
this I was like okay so before kids I
guess tactically
it could be somewhat you like okay yeah
you get these bills out but then you get
the kids I mean I just know for us like
I'm really starting soccer and I have to
buy uniforms I'd be like will you buy
them once yeah like who who does the Zoo
membership either I'm saying like how do
you I don't understand tactically how
you live out life so on a tactical sense
you guys it's so much easier to function
out of one account on a very tactical
high-level surface reason it's like yeah
we're all working out of the same pot so
we can figure out okay where's our money
going we're getting out of debt we're
putting this money here it's easy there
and then what ends up happening out of
that is like yeah we end up talking
about life we end up actually having to
trust each other we end up having to
talk we end up having to fight like
that's all good have hard disagreements
yes because you're all iron sharpens
iron towards a common Mission a common
school because two jobs
or we avoid fighting or the con like
people people that avoid conflict
specifically marriage probably in life
talk to like talk to America about this
because you're just you're good at
communicating this but like you just
lose the depth and the richness of
marriage if you just are in constant
avoidance right and it's going to come
out sideways one way or the other but
but actually like having conflict and
fighting and I'm not saying being
hurtful to your spouse and name cult
right like but being able to have
conflict healthy conflict is really
important for a marriage beneath
conflict is this idea that I have enough
value that I can say out loud what I
need and what I want and when I say out
loud what I need and what I want and I'm
married or I'm dating somebody seriously
I've just entered into a risky
proposition because the other person who
I love and I've dedicated my life to
might say no yep and so instead of
heading into those murky Waters
we just hedge our bets and I ask people
to read my mind I ask my wife to just
imagine what I want for dinner instead
of saying hey I can't do another pasta
dish because I've got gas so like I knew
we need to do something else right and
so I just don't say anything and then I
get home and my wife has been working
her butt off all day for this amazing
pasta dish and my first thought is right
I've just created conflict because I
didn't express my needs out loud because
I was scared of rejection rejection
right of the other side of this thing so
I just hedge it and so everyone has to
know this
a conflict delayed is conflict Amplified
anytime I choose to squash what I feel
squash what I need squash what is true
it will show up and it will have been
lit on fire and so you can deal with it
in the moment in the present
or you can avoid it and it will show up
in the weirdest places and by the way if
you pay the light bill and I pay the
water bill and you pay the rent but I
pay the car insurance
just wait till somebody takes too long
of a shower
and it's like hey I pay that bill and
now you've created division in your
house being married is hard enough right
right don't create extra barriers
towards connection right yes and on the
financial side I'm like
to win long term and to truly have this
level of peace that we talk a lot about
on this show
and to say okay yeah we have goals for
our marriage and for our life we want
this and that and that running on two
separate tracks it's really hard to get
there to go in the same it's much easier
to be like we're gonna jump on the same
road and go down the same path think
about what we don't do think about like
a business you have a marketing
department you have a sales department
and you have the building maintenance
department
all two of these apartments don't look
at the other one and say hey you got the
phone bill we'll get to this bill we'll
get to this bill there's a common pot
that pays the bills right everybody puts
into this thing we do it in our business
but we we just think we're magic and the
rules don't apply at home they just do
yes I want couples who decide hey we're
going all in go all in yep go all in and
if you get burned somebody hurts you
somebody cheats on you whatever and it
doesn't work
know that you went all in not that you
hedged and didn't study for the exam you
got a D on it you're like well I didn't
study yeah study
risk study stun really hard and getting
a d because you probably won't yeah you
probably won't it's a scary conversation
for those of you that may have separate
accounts and you're listening to this
and you're thinking gosh I really do I
want to be try it for 90 days try it for
90 days and risk the hard conversations
you're all gonna have to have in order
to join those accounts it will be worth
it in the long run or it will reveal
that your relationship has bigger issues
than you all are willing to talk about
and that's normal that's normal
welcome to marriage this is the Ramsay
show we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by backed by their
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
welcome back this is the Ramsey Show I'm
John deloney joined by Rachel Cruz and
we're taking your calls on your life
your relationships your money your work
whatever you got going on Triple eight
eight two five five two two five is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to Lynn in the 512
they're in Austin Texas what's up Lynn
hi John hi Rachel thank you so much for
taking my call you got it what's up
so my husband and I are trying to make
any correct decisions
about our house we are completely debt
free all the way through baby step seven
and we are growing out of our house we
hadn't planned on leaving our house for
probably another year or so but we have
some family issues going on
um my family currently lives in our
subdivision and my father struggles with
addiction and it's been ongoing for a
long time and so my husband and I made
the really tough decision of putting
down some really strong boundaries
because we're trying to change our
family tree in more ways than one and so
we've cut off communication that being
said we feel the need to kind of push
moving a little bit sooner than we had
anticipated hey Lynn do you care I'm
sorry do you mind speaking directly into
your phone
just so we can hear you I'm sorry no
you're great you're great I just want to
make sure we can hear you yes that's
better thank you yes yes
um and so we were looking at a house
that was priced um about two hundred
thousand dollars lower than another
house that was priced my husband makes
about 580
000 a year and
we didn't know what to do we feel bad
going into debt at all um so we were
contemplating the input and just saving
up cash and we'll buy a house cash
that'll take us probably about a year to
two years to get the house that that we
were planning on getting or we can get
the less expensive house and if we
financed anything at all it would
probably be somewhere between 75 to 90
000 if even and we think we might even
be able to pay it off before we close
but not 100 sure if we get the more
expensive house it would probably take
us about two and a half to three years
to pay it off and we worked really hard
to become debt free and we were just
trying to do the right thing and just
kind of change our family tree in so
many ways and we are just totally at a
Crossroads because the right thing feels
like either we stay put and just suck it
up with my family and just hope that we
don't run into them my son you know
doesn't keep asking
um we just don't know what to do
um I just need to tell you how proud of
you I am because when you're doing is
very very hard
yes it is
um like emotionally and relationally
this is tough man how old are your kids
and we have one son he's about to be two
ah gee yeah that's tough tough tough
tough
um do you live
uh
is your father in a way that he would
just show up at the house knock on the
door like safety issues that you're
worried about Lynn
shown up before
um when he has gone off to um on one of
his binges and shown up one time and I
was at home with my son by myself and it
scared me it's the one time he's done it
I just don't know what he's capable of
I'd like to say that I think we're okay
but the truth is I don't I don't think
that we will feel safe until we have
more physical space from both of them
because it's it's both of them my mom is
very codependent with him and that's why
we've had a cut off communication from
both of them which was so hard because
it's just it's just not healthy it's
very toxic and I feel like as a parent I
don't parent as well as I could when all
of these things are going on I just want
to be the best parent and wife I can be
and I can't be that when they're still
close in proximity I I just applaud you
for recognizing what you need and what
your family needs and then being willing
to make the hard hard call but most
people in your situation wouldn't have
the courage to do what you're doing
that's incredible so um I've got a
couple of principles that I live by and
so I'm going to put the principles out
and I'm going to give you an idea and
then Rachel I want you to tell me if
this is crazy okay
principle number one is I don't let
somebody else
hurt my family
and so that is both physical that is
both show up in the middle of the night
if I'm unsafe right that might be
getting a relationship with the police
that might be moving okay that also
means I'm not going to
to the best of my ability
I'm not going to put my family at risk
financially either
and so I don't want to violate my
principles in an Escape Route
unless I absolutely have to I don't want
to drive 110 miles an hour unless
somebody's going to die if I don't do
this and so that's that's
um
that's the first principle there I want
to hold my values and for you and your
family one of your core values has been
we don't borrow money we work too hard
to get here
the second core value
um is I rarely ever outside of
significant abuse
I reject the either or thinking because
when I box myself into an either or
moment I make a bad emotional decision
and so here's a third option so your
options are in your mind are we stay
here and I can't breathe because I never
know if that knock is coming on the door
or if Dad's just going to barge in or if
my two-year-old's gonna be playing
outside in the yard and whatever
or we got to go buy a house and we have
to go through we weren't going to move
just yet but we got to do this we gotta
do this
a third option maybe we sell our house
ASAP and we might do it with no sign in
the yard so we might even take a little
bit less and get it sold tell the
realtor hey we want we don't want to
Market this thing but we want it just
gone and there in Austin you'll get a
good return on it and we're going to
rent for a year
or two years and we're gonna give
ourselves a chance to breathe because
what I want you guys to do is to go
towards something not just Sprint away
from something because you're going to
end up buying a house that you can't
afford you're going to end up buying too
small of a house and within 18 months
your husband makes half a million
dollars a year you're gonna be so mad
that you didn't buy the house you
actually wanted yeah and you just find
yourself in this little limbo so go rent
a house y'all make so much money you can
rent a nice house how much can you sell
your house for Lynn
about 450 okay
yeah that's what I was going to say is
is my my caution around making such a
big move meaning selling something and
buying a home which is your two largest
transactions that most people make in
their lifetime we're not talking about a
used car here right I mean it's your
home it's your residence and so to not
let the high emotion and that urgency
create a bad financial decision when
there's another path like John was
saying of just renting right and and
what that does Lynn is it is it lets you
breathe from the safety of your home and
that dysfunction that you were
explaining to us because you have this
physical distance and that's going to
give you peace as a mom with a
two-year-old like I can only imagine
just to be like I just need to sleep at
night just to know the distance that
we're in I think that's a really
important factor in this I mean I really
do
um so I want that for you but then on
the financial side I don't want you to
rush into something that again it's your
largest purchase uh that again most
people make in their lifetime with their
primary residents so I don't want you
rushing into that with this High emotion
either so I think getting some space
physically is going to help that
distance and it's going to slow you guys
down in the process because what I don't
want Lynn is about yes sorry get into
the house that you think you might be
able to cash for the 75 to 90 and it's
the less expensive house but it's
working now go go and like John said you
look up in 24 months and you're like man
we really wanted the other one and we
could have had it and we have plenty of
money it could have been and we don't
want to move you know like all of that
so the renting I think is a really it
solves both issues for you guys to be
able to save and continue to cash flow
the property that you really want and
honestly Lin too I would say 12 months
from now who knows what you know what's
up for sale too right so just giving you
guys this patience that it's not this
this is my only thing or it's not and
let's call this out moving is the worst
yeah it's gonna be moving with a
two-year-old
super the worst and
your husband makes half a million
dollars and so it's also an ego buster
too we rented for 10 years I know I know
I know gotta put the ego aside yeah oh
you are changing your family tree ego
makes you do stupid things that's right
that's right that's right every time and
here's the thing your husband makes half
a million dollars pay someone pay
somebody
every
you would say we're going to Hawaii and
we're back our crap better be moved to
this house yeah I would do it like that
and I'd pay the money and have it done
you're just in a you're in a season of
blessing right now I would do that and I
would I would I love what you said
Rachel this is like almost a nervous
system move we're gonna create peace in
our home
and then we're going to start making
some of these challenging decisions
moving forward yeah I'm sorry
[Music]
Landry's especially family that's close
like that's so hard it's so hard so well
done I applaud you guys and the story
you will tell that you had to rent again
even with husband making a bajillion
it's just all part of the story that
will be told with how you changed your
family tree it's amazing this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey listen paying off debt is smart and
saving and investing is smart but
there's one key to winning with money
that people Overlook all the time and
that's protecting your finances from
emergencies
Rachel nobody likes to pay for insurance
but insurance Saves the Day always ten
kinds of insurance coverage you might
need based on what your life looks like
today so we've built a tool called the
coverage checkup to show you what types
you need to add drop or adjust we'll
even rank your coverage list by
importance and tell you hey you got to
do this one right now and we're going to
email it to you and connect you with
Ramsey trusted insurance providers so
you can get your plan in place fast and
Rachel here's what's important about
these kind of ads
we all use this stuff too this is what
we do in our homes right so this isn't
us just chilling something out there
that's right this is what keeps our
family safe as well yes whether it's
umbrella policies life insurance car
insurance auto I mean all of it it's uh
it's so important and like you said I
I'm such a spender so when I see chunks
of money just leaving and I don't
see it whether it's even investing and
I'm like I know 60 year old Rachel will
be very happy but right now I'm like
well by the way right now I can like do
some stuff with that or a lot of our
insurance is quarterly I don't know how
you and Sheila have your setup and so
like this month was one and it was like
in our every dollar budget and I see the
amount we pay and I'm like but then our
roof something happened because there
was a hail storm and all this stuff we
got a check to fix the roof I'm like
well that's kind of nice two hours on
the annual plan and it hurts it's not
fun I know but all this stuff happens
right well not to bring down a room but
I've sat with too many oh yes widows
who've lost their husband I look at and
there's a it's just a hollow look and
they say what do I do now right so
future John that you know God forbid
something happened to my family yep is
going to be really grateful that we do
this so listen visit ramseysolutions.com
checkup it's ramseysolutions.com checkup
don't let an emergency sneak up on you
just be ready be ready and have peace
all right let's go out to will in the
ATL and see what's up what's up will
hey how are y'all we're partying man
what are you up to
um okay so I just had a few questions
kind of on the same topic and I just
kind of wanted to get your advice on
them
um so I'm 18 and I have just recently
opened a Roth IRA
Q
um and I just kind of wanted to get
y'all's opinion on like how much should
I put in there right now how much should
I be saving for an engagement ring that
I'm possibly going to be buying in the
next year or for a down payment on a
house or things like that like where
should the focus of my finances be going
towards dang 18 will you got a lot going
on so are you uh I was trying to get
somebody to date me at 18.
buying a Roth IRA who are you man you're
like you're like AI will you're not even
real
ize
our financial piece and all that stuff I
grew up under a good houseboat
18 year old's doing great okay well are
you doing College are you in are you
working full-time what's your status
no okay so I didn't go to college I
graduated
um high school and now I'm working as a
superintendent for a Contracting Company
okay and so that's that's for the
foreseeable future that's what you'll be
doing
yes great and how much do you make a
year
um about 40 before taxes okay great
so I'll start with the engagement ring
um we always recommend about a month's
worth of salary to spend on an
engagement ring so uh that's kind of the
that's the rule of thumb so I'd have
that number in in your head to say okay
that kind of feels that feels right uh
and then I would walk you through the
baby steps right now saving for a house
uh it sounds like you have a lot of Life
transitions possibly coming in the next
two three years of your life so buying a
house right now I think would be
probably not the smartest investment
just because the amount of change that
could be occurring of maybe it's another
job change or if you do get engaged and
you're married and you guys move City
like I mean there's just a lot that can
happen
so it's saving for a down payment right
this moment I probably wouldn't Focus so
much on
but I would focus on an emergency fund
do you just have cash in the bank
um yes and I already have a little money
in my Ross Ira that I put in how much do
you have just liquid cash that's in the
bank
um I have like 445
100 4 500 okay and are you living at
home
um yes but that's possibly in transition
to moving with my brother okay okay
um but that's still going to be paying
just partial rent right
yes yes okay okay that's great yeah so
as long as that 4500 do you if you feel
like is a good you know three month
emergency fund for your seasonal life
right now then you can leave that and
then yeah I mean I would I would put 15
of your income into that Roth I wouldn't
worry about maxing it out I would just
worry about that 15 because also we'll
you have so much time right like I mean
you're fine I wouldn't I wouldn't Focus
so much on just like oh my gosh you have
to put everything away even though
compound interest I get all of that but
if you're putting 15 of your income at
18 years old you're gonna be just fine
so anything extra I would save and just
a high yield savings accounts just for
the big transitions coming up AKA a ring
possibly a what you know the wedding uh
a down payment on a home all of that
that's kind of where I would be focused
on if I were if I was 18 that would be
my goal and I'm going to tell you
something that everybody is going to
um in your life that is around you is
going to tell you the opposite okay
and I'm right
okay so everyone else around you is
going to give you dumb advice this is
the right advice are you ready
yeah I think it would be wise to spend
your first year of marriage if you get
messy get married at 19 you get married
at 20 I think it would be very wise for
you all to spend the first year of your
marriage renting someplace whether it's
a small house or an apartment or a
whatever
putting the stress of home ownership on
a 19 or 20 year old who's just in a
first year of marriage is madness you
won't recognize you right now when
you're 21. you'll be you'll have had
three to five years experience on a
construction crew you'll have a couple
years of marriage you'll be having kids
or thinking about kids or thinking about
going back to school I want you to be as
you know if you want to get married get
married oh I'm not going to talk you out
of that that's between you and your
future wife and your pastor and all that
kind of stuff but I want you to be as
flexible as possible because life's
going to be sideways and changing and
moving and ups and down all that stuff
over the next three to five years and so
keep building keep you way ahead of the
game your biggest challenge is going to
be not trying to dump too much jet fuel
into a really great car that you have
and burning the engine up because man
you are on a trajectory Rachel said
you're going to be just fine I'll
rephrase it you're gonna to be stupid
wealthy
if you're already at 18 putting money in
a Roth already thinking about saving you
are so far ahead of the game you can't
even you can't even understand it at 18.
so I want you to have as much joy in
your life and be flexible and be
learning and learning and learning and
working not stressing over a new roof or
we need to fix this or we got to fix the
bathroom all that kind of crap that
comes with home ownership so again well
just 15 of your income into that Roth
and then anything extra you have just
put away for savings because there's
going to be expenses coming up in the
future and waiting a year after you guys
get married to actually purchase a home
like John said all right let's go out to
Eric in chaitan in Chicago what's up
Eric
we're right up against the clock so it
goes as fast as you can
okay I'm because we're on baby step two
and I'm considering pausing my 401k
contributions and using that money
to pay down the debt even faster correct
Eric yes ding ding ding that is the
correct answer pay it off pay it off pay
it off pay it off pay it off yeah so
that's the one one of the things that
people cringe at some of our advice
honestly it's one of the things like
wait what pause investing yes pause
investing and throw that extra money out
just like you said to get out of debt
that much faster and then you can press
play on that debt so Eric uh how much
how much debt do you guys have
um told about eighty thousand dollars
okay yes awesome pause it all pause it
all pause it all and pay that debt off
as quickly as possible all right for the
call yeah thanks for the call brother
hey that's the first hour in the books
here way to go Rachel you're getting
better at this well done John you did
okay I'm a radio sensation
[Music]
[Applause]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your mental
health and your relationships and your
money and your emotional health all of
it and I'm John deloney joined here by
Rachel Cruz and we are taking your calls
toll-free Triple Eight triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Rachel we doing well doing great
Hey listen before we take a call
um we have to shout out our friends
um Joshua Fields Milburn and Ryan
Nicodemus and TK Coleman
otherwise known as the minimalist three
in this in this world that we're in
there's really extraordinary people and
then there's some tough people to be
around and they may be three of them
extraordinary guys
um they have their documentary that has
been seen by over 80 million people
right so good and they're rolling it off
of Netflix onto YouTube I think this
Sunday I think it's this weekend yes yep
so make sure to check it out you guys
and there's they're doing an I think
like a I want to say like a no ad
version of it so the more traffic that
goes to it the better just just to help
them because the algorithm and stuff of
all these things you know what I mean so
like
um it's an incredible documentary and
just to support them because it's the
basis of so much of what we talk about
on the show how materialism consumerism
has taken over our lives here in America
which is one of the routes that has
caused so much debt so
um the beauty in just the Simplicity of
what really is true in life what is
really true in life so they they are
incredible so make sure to check that
out and just a little peek behind the
scenes this this summer
um when I was finishing up I don't say
finishing up is about halfway through
with a new book that I'm working on
um I got stuck and I got stuck in a way
that
I realized I wasn't living some of these
things I was writing about and I didn't
know where to go and one of the first
people I was like I gotta call Josh
right like that yeah he's somebody Ryan
is somebody TK somebody that I trust
when I need some insight onto something
um and so they're great people behind
closed doors their documentary is
amazing so check it out on YouTube this
Sunday night
um it's the minimalist we're pretty
excited for them good good for them all
right let's go out to uh Hannah in
Boston let's see Hannah where are we at
there you are hey Hannah what's up
Hi how are you partying how about you
I'm good thank you thanks so much for
taking our call of course thanks for
calling what's up
so my boyfriend and I were both 22
um we're going to be graduating college
within the next year and um we're kind
of hoping to to figure out some some way
to move out within the next um two to
three years
um we're just a bit worried as we're
going to have pretty significant student
loans combined and I'm going to be a
teacher so that salary isn't ideal
um so we're just kind of hoping to find
the next steps how to how to set
ourselves up for financial success
essentially yeah it's a great question
um
so I would say my my first piece of
advice Hannah is when you are not
legally married to not combine finances
so you kept saying like our student
loans are going to be significant and
all that I would keep things very
separate and very clean until you guys
get married so how how much student loan
will you have Hannah
so I'll have about 30 grand and then
Brett will have roughly
120. okay and what's he doing is he
gonna be a doctor
no so he's actually going to be a
mechanical engineer
um but he went to school out of state uh
so that's fine yes yeah
so for you Hannah you'll be you said
you'll be graduating next year
so coming up in May yep May that's great
okay and are you what else financially
where are you at do you have any uh
money saved are you working what's your
status so I I do work um as a nanny in
addition to being a full-time student so
I I do have roughly 10 grand saved right
now
um and I we don't have any other you
know loans our cars we bought them
outright
um so it's really only the student loans
that are the concern okay and
um
yeah so so Hannah I mean I'll just kind
of be frank with you just because you're
the one that called is again you kept
saying our our car is our like start
thinking you're you're welcome no you're
totally fine but I do think especially
on a financial sense it's really
important to to to not feel the
obligation or responsibility for his
loans Hannah you need to take care of
yours right so like keeping these things
very separate yep is really key so yeah
for you I mean 30 grand you have 10
grand saved which is awesome so what
what I would do Hannah if I woke up in
your shoes is
my senior year I would just save save
save save save save do what you can to
save and then when you graduate
hopefully you'll have you know you know
maybe 20 grand saved yep uh 25 Grand so
you'll be able to knock out the student
loan your student loan out pretty
quickly even on a teacher's salary uh
you'll be able to get through this
pretty great pretty quick which is
awesome and then we'll let you know
Brett figure out you know his job and
what he's going to be doing and what he
can do with his 120 but
um but again I really would um
keep harping that that these are yours
don't feel because you sound very kind
Hannah and very sweet and Brett sounds
mean
that's great that's awesome I'm sure
it's great but I would just I would I
would keep my lives separate in that
sense uh and then once you guys get
married then we can have a whole other
discussion of what this looks like
together but we just heard so many
horror stories Hannah again of and I
would say this too if even you know
people moving in together and they're
sharing bills and they're trying to
they're trying to act married when
they're not and I think we can go to the
emotional route down that John if you
want to do that you can but or but just
the financial route I think when they
when you're not married keeping things
separate until you actually are married
and then be married you know there's a
um there's a legal process for
separating
assets when you're married yeah it is a
train wreck trying to separate assets
when you're just dating
and the forensic account is just such a
mess
um yeah yeah yeah that I mean that's
that's what comes down and you're not
gonna like this that I'm saying this
um and I totally if you say anything
other than well that's not us I would
think something was wrong with you but
Rachel and I wouldn't have a job if
things didn't happen that people didn't
see coming
and everybody is confident in their
relationship and you work really hard
and help pay off his student loans and
then all of a sudden he's gone or vice
versa he pays off all of your student
loans and then you meet some hot PE
teacher and it's all over Hannah right
so yeah all that to say is life happens
um really if I'm you and you were my
sister or you were my my close friend I
would tell you find the cheapest place
you can safely live and I would focus
the first two years of teaching on
paying these off and you will then be
able to be the teacher that you want to
be because you're not going to feel
Shackled like I can't say this thing or
I can't do this thing because I don't
want to get fired I got to pay my
student loans it totally unhooks you
from the Matrix in that way
um and then maybe if
um Brett here he can get a move on and
if Brett's the one put a ring on that's
what I'm saying let's go Brett
um get all this better if he wants to
propose on air I accept that we can do
that on here that'd be incredible I
don't think Brad's gonna like you John
no I love bread I love bread I think
he's about to lose Hannah to some PE
teacher who needs to get a move on let's
go Brent let's go let's do this hey um
teachers man you guys are amazing
amazing amazing thank you hope you're
enjoying your summer yes enjoy your
summer let's make it happen
foreign
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey welcome back this is the Ramsey Show
I'm John deloney joined by Rachel Cruz
and we're taking your calls on money in
life let's go to Michael in Norfolk
Virginia what's up Michael how we doing
brother
hey how you doing how you doing John
Rachel outstanding man what's up
hey so I got a quick question for you uh
so my family and I'm going on baby step
six we have no other debt other than the
mortgage uh and don't freak out but I've
lost a lot of money in crypto yeah you
have Michael
yeah hey are you on speakerphone man
I'm not uh are you up are you having a
tough time hearing me yeah it's a little
bit distant like you're talking to me
through a toilet paper roll can you talk
directly into the phone
yes give me one second let me see if I
can
get a little louder
is that any better yeah much better
Michael yes Michael okay perfect all
right perfect it took the case off again
okay so a lot of a lot of money cardio
and I felt like I just completely felt
my family
um so so dark place during that time uh
I've been studying researching ways to
recover uh but ironically I was taking
all the baby steps without any knowledge
of this program uh which was kind of
cool uh but my question is so I'm active
duty military uh and I know the next
step is to invest the rest of our
savings towards the mortgage which we
have about 51 000 in Vanguard mutual
funds however we're a little bit
hesitant to do that uh because right now
it's 268 000 per mortgage uh 2.25
interest rate
um but I'm in the military and I'm going
to transfer around 2025 so at that point
I think I was committed is to sell the
home do we buy another house or do we
just rent this house and
um rent this house out and rent at
another location
because I don't know how this the baby
sets will tie into somebody who would
have to sell their home sure yeah so
what I would recommend Michael is I
would I would still make that the goal
of paying down the house because you're
going to get it back in equity right so
when you guys sell you'll be able to
have the equity because the what ends up
happening is that we say sometimes is
that people earmark and say okay well I
have you know this money saved over on
the side and uh I could put it towards
the house but we could keep it for a
down payment down the road or we could
use it you know for something else and
or it with the intention of using it
still for Real Estate instead of paying
on the home we'll use it for a future
home but end up that like you know life
ends up happening and you end up taking
money out of that account that was
supposed to be directed towards your
real estate but it's actually being
directed towards a vacation or a new car
or something right so like the money
ends up not doing what it's supposed to
be doing so I would still keep paying
down the house because again you're
putting money into the home you're going
to get it back out when you guys sell
and then when you guys move in 2025 then
I would sell that get all that equity
and if you guys are going to be
somewhere short-term for most active
military we recommend renting because we
want you to be somewhere for at least
five years to actually own a home and so
it makes things easier not to be a
long-distance landlord so to sell and
then if you're going to be somewhere
less than five years to just rent and
you can keep that yeah a Vanguard
account is great put it
um you know I mean yeah that's still a
great option I think vanguard's still
great or you can just do a high yield
savings account because right now you're
getting close to five percent which is
crazy but that's more kind of your
short-term mentality do you know when
you'll be out of the military when
you're going to retire
yeah so uh yeah I took a look at it if
we throw the 51 000 towards at 268 we
can also afford to throw an additional
thousand dollars a month we would have
the house paid off around 2032. that
would be around that same time for my
retirement okay
yeah but you guys are going to be moving
though maybe
potentially potentially with that kind
of up in the air okay I could actually
stay here up until 2032 okay see if
anything could happen essentially
Michael that that is what I want you to
hang your hat on
so I'm gonna see tell me if I'm wrong at
any point
you work in the military
you are active duty you hang around with
a lot of active duty guys
y'all have a lot of you know this could
happen and this could happen and quite
honestly you see things that the average
civilian doesn't
and
that was why you put all the money in
crypto because this is going to happen
bro and then it didn't and so you're a
guy always looking ahead to try to keep
everybody safe that's your job that's
your life that's what you do
and I would challenge you to look back
two and a half years
at what happened in the world just from
right now
and then cast forward and think about
2025 or the middle of 2025 will have
been through another presidential
election God help us all we'll have been
through who knows what geopolitical
nonsense who know all that to say is you
don't know
and so if you have orders if you've got
paper in front of you that says 2025
we're shipping you off to X Y and Z I
think this is a different conversation
but I think what has gotten you in
trouble in the past is trying to guess
the future and trying to somehow hack
your way towards safety and the biggest
concerning thing you said is
I feel a lot of Shame about losing money
in the market and I'm trying to make it
up and when we make it up we end up
making an emotional rash decision and we
do something else goofy I would tell you
the greatest gift you can give your
family right now is the gift of
stability
here we're going to slowly March these
baby steps we're going to keep them
rolling and if I get papers that say
we're moving then we're going to make
that decision when we get there maybe we
have an extra deep freezer with some
meat just in case but we are going to do
this thing methodically and that's going
to be my gift to my family not this
illusion that we're going to somehow
avoid the media right if it happens to
come one day someday maybe possibly but
we're just going to slow and steady wins
the race does that make sense
yeah that absolutely does thank you John
I know that's the worst I know dude I
know it's I know it's the worst
but Michael too
from Attack to hormone tactical but I
just want to make sure Michael that you
still have some cash that's available to
you for an emergency fund so make sure
you do that don't throw oh okay just
don't want to throw all the cash
we have about a four-month emergency
fund to emphasize that that's completely
separate okay excellent excellent
excellent that's fantastic man well done
and thanks for your service Michael yeah
I really appreciate you guys good for
you hey and thanks for just being one of
those guys that you made a dumb mistake
with money and you owned it and now
you're looking to the Future to uh be a
good Steward of your financial resources
for you and your family and your
community good for you man it's awesome
so many people just hide and run and
they just spend all their time on
YouTube and that's not you man so good
for you let's go out to ATL and talk to
Brandon what's up Brandon
hey what's going on John and Rachel how
are you excellent excellent what's up
man
not much so I had a quick question so my
wife and I we just paid off our last 20
000 student loans yeah congratulations
yeah thank you we are so excited but
we're now looking into rewind a whole
two days and I got accepted to a
part-time MBA program and I'm trying to
figure out if we're in the right spot
financially in terms of the baby steps
to go ahead and take that on
all right so uh so you guys are
completely debt free because you just
paid off your student loans I'm guessing
right correct cool that's great correct
uh do you guys have savings at all
uh yes we have about nineteen thousand
dollars in the bank right now between
checking and savings okay
um and then like a tiny tiny amount in a
um non-retirement
um investment fund okay and are you guys
both working
yes so I make about 70 000 my wife makes
about 55 so 125
000 growth between the two of us what is
this MBA Gonna Get You
um so I doing the projections and the
field I want to go into which is just
Financial analytics it it looks like
this could get me probably about a forty
thousand dollar raise from where I am
today so it's really career growth okay
are you able to still be are you going
to be working while you're doing this or
would you just go to school full time
yeah okay and so the part-time evening
MBA
um costs would be about seven to ten
Grand a semester but I've also got a two
thousand dollar scholarship and
potentially a five thousand dollar
tuition reimbursement from my employer
my gosh the academic paid for it which I
still have to figure out which you could
have it paid I mean so that would pay
for everything well it'd be at one time
five thousand oh oh not not like per
year yeah so the 5000 is a yearly every
year that's awesome yeah yeah so I mean
Brandon I mean yeah you are in a
position totally to go back to school as
long as you're cash flowing it which you
guys could even if some of this didn't
come through you could you guys make the
money right to be able to cash flow it
um and it paid for mbas it's a great
it's a great Arrow to have in your
quiver yeah for sure and the ROI is
there like you said you've already run
out the numbers so it's an extra forty
thousand dollars per year uh that you'll
make so yeah I mean go say go for it I
would I pause paying off your house and
cash flow yourself through college and
then make a run at it good for you
brother good job
[Music]
job
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls on money and life I'm
John deloney joined here by Rachel Cruz
let's run out to James in Knoxville
right down the street what's up James
hi Rachel hi John how are you we're
great man how are you well better than I
deserve outstanding outstanding what's
up man
well I'm a I was just reaching out I'm a
little discouraged right now with um
um
home ownership and eventually getting to
the point of buying a house
um
I'm I'm currently on the plan and I'm
not too soon to finish up baby step two
but soon enough but I'm just I'm a
teacher and it's with the salary versus
the home prices in the area it's just
really discouraging to
know if I will ever be able
to own a home
yeah no I hear you
um so what how old are you James
30 okay and how much do you make a year
between my teaching job and all my other
jobs right at 60. okay
and we'll put our not what part of
Knoxville are you in
um the South area okay that's Knoxville
yeah so what are what are homes going
for down there right now
well looking within the area
um I'm gonna say reasonably about three
hundred thousand okay
do you have a family
I do not no man
great well
um I mean I can I can share in the
frustration of the market I mean it's
been a wacky uh few years for housing
it's it's stabilized uh which is which
is great but also uh the values and
everything are up obviously interest
rates are are higher than what they were
at two percent uh back in the day so so
I understand the frustration and the
hard thing is James when it comes to
money
and looking at what you can't afford is
it's really looking at the math and John
talks a lot about this that that facts
are your friends and even though we have
emotions around things whether it's
talking to an 18 year old and they want
to go to a private out of state college
but they can't afford it they're they're
frustrated about that and I get that
they don't have to choose a different
option right so uh so what I would say
to you James is that I don't think that
it's not out it's not out of the picture
I mean making 60 Grand is you're doing
great and you know you're single so even
what type of house or type of living
situation residents you're looking at
you're looking at you know you could
even open up the door to options of a
town home you know owning some type of
real estate is a great goal to have for
your overall Financial picture so I
would continue
to tell you to to go there it may take
you longer to save up a five ten percent
down payment for something but I
wouldn't take it completely out of the
question but where you're looking and
the type of home you're looking at may
have to shift that expectation May shift
which is frustrating and that's not fun
and all that but I think
the reality of which of what you're
where you're at is is what you have to
focus on so James
um tell me if if this is part of of the
frustration too
my dad was was a policeman
and I remember the frustration this was
he never said this out loud but it was
just in the air of our home
this idea that our local community paid
policemen so poor
that he was took a job of public service
and didn't have enough money barely had
enough money to buy a house and and we
struggled with groceries sometimes and
we had a one-car house it's like we
lived this extravagant Crazy Life
and then brother I was a public school
teacher for a few years in Texas
I couldn't have bought a house and that
was before the numbers went crazy
and I remember that same sense of I went
to college I got a degree I'm a teacher
and I can't buy a home like I remember
that haunting my wife was a teacher for
years that same thing so part of that
frustration right is going to be I did
everything right yeah yeah the overall
choices and I can't afford to live in my
own Community right is that some of this
James
that is part of it yes yes and I you
know it wasn't always this way no it
wasn't it wasn't it it wasn't and even
looking at
um going back to Rachel looking at Town
Homes you can't even find a town home
for a decent price yeah everything in
the area
they get goggled gobble up for college
students
um
Rachel's right and I hate to be I hate
to I hate to Second her on this one is
we can't get a pass on math
and so the
questions you have to answer that nobody
can answer for you are
is this the career path forward for you
or am I gonna have to commute a little
bit further because I was put on Earth
to be a teacher
or I'm going to take my skills that I've
developed over the last X number of
years as a teacher and I'm going to
apply them in this setting instead of
this setting
but the math part doesn't change and
those are all questions we don't want to
answer we don't like those they're not
fun like they they weren't they weren't
part of the the script we were given in
high school and we were told if you just
go to college and get a degree
everything's gonna be a fine
um that wasn't part of the script and so
I think it's having that honest
conversation with yourself and
recognizing how long have you been on
baby step two man
um
a little over a year dude you're at
Beatdown stage
you work all these extra jobs and you're
a teacher and you're exhausted and
you're so tired it wasn't even worth
failing a couple of those kids because
you don't want the paperwork and the
fights with the principal you're all of
that and trying to pay debt off and you
see there's no shiny new things there's
no going out to eat you're at the
frustrating part of baby step two right
uh I could I could agree with that
I could agree with that I absolutely
could yeah so I guess at the end of the
day I wish there was a magic pill Rachel
that we could give yeah you know and I
know the Knoxville area so I'm thinking
like the Powell area South Doyle I mean
like there's there's places James of of
just and again if it means driving
another 20 minutes
uh that may be it and that's and that's
the frustrating thing about the whole
housing conversation jobs and you're not
the only one we've had this conversation
with and our own team has experienced
this as they're trying to find houses
like I get it it's so it's so annoying
to think gosh 2019 was just a different
world uh that we live in versus today
what I could have gotten versus what I
do now and it's just all it is this
um it's this level of grappling with
reality that you have to be able to say
okay if I want this I have to believe I
can and not in some like fairy tale way
naive way but to be like I really am
going to lay out a plan between now and
the next five years that I have a goal
to own something within real estate so
what does that look like does that mean
changing possibly changing careers does
that mean looking and broadening where
I'm looking uh because I really I I have
confidence James that you can do this
because we talk to people on the show
all the time that make these decisions
but it's not overnight and like John
said where you are in the process you're
in a hard spot and you saw the baby step
3 to save up for an emergency fund right
so you're still years out for this and
the world could look a whole lot
different in four years James when
you're actually seriously looking at
purchasing something or starting to save
for it so give yourself some time it is
a marathon this whole thing it is it is
years it's not this instance
um effect that you're going to have
these new results overnight it's just
not and I wish we did have a oh yeah oh
man that's what's frustrating about this
industry is I feel like there are things
out there that are like flashy and like
oh just do this and this and this and
this and people get into those things
thinking they're going to get a quick
turn
and then they get screwed and they lose
money so it's like this is the smartest
wisest path but it's slow James it's
slow and it's and I get it it's not fun
but um one of the cornerstones of
emotional health one of the cornerstones
of relational health is owning reality
just choosing reality here is where we
are and as hard as that is I promise
that the work your body is doing trying
being frustrated about this and being
mad about that and wishing for this that
energy spent is energy that could be
going into solving a real challenge for
you so if your marriage is sideways
avoiding the conversation does not heal
that yeah
um being a world-class teacher in a
great part of the country
doesn't change the math of I want to own
a home so like Rachel said okay five
years what's it going to take for me to
do from here to there five years and I'm
gonna just Echo this too John because we
feel this in our County here in
Nashville how frustrating it is that
teachers aren't paid what they should
what they're worth I know and they can't
even live in the county that they teach
like that's all you legislators who are
just throwing sand at each other in your
sandbox Pay Teachers and cops for God's
sakes good grief
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you for taking my call how are we
doing we're dude we are partying that's
probably not totally true we're at work
but we're doing good man how about you
oh it's too good to complain too good to
complain excellent man what's up how can
we help
so I'm a physical therapy student I'm
about to graduate in a year I'm happily
married and we're operating right now
solely on my wife's income we both
opened up our Roth IRAs last year and
we're not quite saving enough this year
to fully fund them we have a fully
funded emergency fund with 18 000 in
excess and a high-yield savings and we
have 21
000 in a brokerage account invested in
mutual funds so our question is do we
take out money from our brokerage
account to fund our Roth IRAs this year
are you cash flowing your PT school
yes sir
good for you man yeah that's great uh so
how much is your wife making
she's making forty five thousand forty
five thousand okay and then you have not
been working but you will be I'm
assuming
I work in between semesters so super
part-time okay that's great uh so yeah
so you guys have no debt you have good
savings for an emergency fund and that
18 may even be high uh depending on what
your expenses are
um so honestly Chris I wouldn't look at
maxing it out I would just fund 15 of
that 45
000 into the Roth does she have a 401k
yes so we both have Roth IRAs on our own
and then she has a Roth IRA through her
company as well this company matches up
to three percent right now and so this
is contributing three and then perfect
they contribute to 50 of six percent
after six months of her being there okay
so I would yeah concentrate on that
three and then the other 12 I would just
throw at the Roth whatever that math
ends up being uh and and I so it would
not you wouldn't be maxing it out which
is okay and then when you guys start
working again it's 15 of your total
income taking that match if you get in a
match with your employer taking that and
then going back to the Roth and if you
Max it out at 65 6500 is what you can do
uh that's the maximum in 2023 so if you
guys end up maxing that out after you
get full-time work then I would just go
back to your 401ks and Max those out
which I think it's like 22 500 to Max
them out um this calendar year so that's
where I would focus we always tell
people that match beats Roth beats
traditional so always focusing on that
match first that you can get in the 401K
and then going to the Roth IRA so even
though you guys have the cash Chris I
wouldn't necessarily look at just
completely you know
maxing out the the Roth if you don't if
you don't have to I mean I would
I don't know that's what I would do you
guys have a do you have a mortgage
yes we have about 105 left on our
mortgage okay but we're looking to move
in about a year or two okay so yeah I
mean I would focus on using some of this
money even in the brokerage account to
to throw at this mortgage and kind of
get that get some equity in the house
how old are you Chris
24 24. you guys are doing great so we
are doing awesome have you got to do a
clinical rotation yet
I'm actually on a clinical rotation
right now in a separate City for my wife
so we are okay so you're getting it done
so have you had the opportunity to work
with somebody who had like a devastating
shoulder or knee injury and they were
kind of a hot shot and now they're
working their way back and all of your
PT colleagues are buzzing about the
great progress this person has made but
this person only
has this vision of themselves doing you
know these amazing things and so they
lose the force for the trees have you
experienced that yet
yes I have okay that's you
you are 24. you have no debt your cash
flowing a graduate degree
you are absolutely
so far ahead of 24 year olds that we
talk to
that you're even having this thought
you're ahead of 24 year olds when you
said you were a PT student I it's so
rare that I meet a PT student that's
cash flow in college it's it's
unbelievable you're so far ahead of the
game and I don't want you to lose the
force for the trees y'all aren't failing
the fact that you even know what a Roth
IRA is sets you into the the upper two
percent of planet Earth right you're so
far ahead
I don't want you guys to burn a hole
through your marriage and burn a hole
through this exciting Fun Time of Your
Life worried that you're not maxing this
out or not maximizing this out bro you
are y'all are doing incredible okay
yes sir get through school debt free get
your new job wherever you're going to be
you'll get settled in somewhere yeah and
man then you can start saying okay I'm
making 75 or 100 you're making 45 now we
can start really getting ahead here but
dude that 15 where you guys are with
that 45 I would I would stick with that
there's no reason to pay my house off
and put some cash aside you're doing
great Chris you're so far ahead I'm
proud of you man it's really great let's
run out to uh Atlanta Georgia and talk
to Trish what's up Trish
all right yeah thank you for taking my
call of course what's happening
so my question is do I need to pay off
my collection accounts before paying off
my regular debt
okay so what's your uh how much is in
collections
about
15 000. okay
okay what's the Dead on
um old credit cards that I wasn't able
to pay off in time
um a caller possession
um that's pretty much it some medical
bills is it all lumped together in the
same company or you got multiple uh it
kind of sprinkled around sprinkled
around okay
uh and then how much other debt do you
have Trish
so I have a total I have a hundred and
eighty on the house okay
and then I've got 50 on car payments
and then my student loan is a total of a
hundred thousand okay how much do you
make a year
about 130 130 okay and you said 50 on
cars is that a single card two cars it's
two cars two cars
and are you single married
unmarried married okay
um so just to answer yeah your Tactical
question I mean when debts go into
collection I mean they're they've been
probably
run through four different other
collections companies and they buy and
sell this these debts and all of it so
it's it's tangled up meaning most of the
time you can negotiate
and actually get these debts lowered
um do you guys have any cash
we have a thousand dollar emergency fund
okay okay
so yeah if I were you I would get that
000 cleaned up the ones that are in
collections and again Trish I if if you
can I would call and and I would gather
as much cash as you can Trish like I I
would take this income that you guys
make me make great income and and next
month I mean you you guys aren't doing
anything you're not going out to eat
you're not going on vacation like July
at Trisha's house means we are barely
eat we're eating ramen noodles and beans
and rice like we're not we're nothing
fancy and we are selling stuff look
around your house if it's not bolted to
the ground sell it get cash because when
you can have some cash and actually call
these collectors and say hey I have this
available and I'm able to write a check
to you today for this amount versus what
I owe they're much more apt to take that
deal
and actually you know and you can and
you can get the deal on it and so if you
do that and go down that route make sure
you get everything in writing first and
foremost
um but I would make that my my July
August honestly is calling all these
collections these collectors and just
talking to them and saying okay what
would you guys take I have this amount
it's not a lot here would you settle
um to get this 15 down but I would work
on that and then
how what's the difference in the cars 50
50 is total what's on each car
I got about 35 on one
and then
15 in the morning okay what's that 35
000 car worth
um
maybe 20
20. wow okay so you're way upside down
on that thing yep
okay so Trish this is gonna be it's
gonna be a process I want you to hold on
the line and Skyler's gonna pick up and
I want you and your husband to go
through Financial Peace University
because it feels like things are a
little bit scattered and all over the
place and I want you guys together on a
plan to walk through this we're gonna
give you every dollar plus which
attaches to your base Financial coach
too here yep so hold on the line Trish
and we'll help you out thanks for
calling hey this has been another hour
in the books this is the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we have a conversation
about your money your life and actual
amazing relationships I'm John deloney
joined by my good friend Rachel Cruz and
we're taking your calls on everything
whatever you got going on in your life
I'm confident we have an opinion on it
and we have an actual amazing
relationship please call in John is the
one if you're a relationship is not
amazing call in give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go out to Nick in Portland what's
up Nick
I thank you for having me on today and
my question to get to the point is back
in 2011 I was being paralyzed by debt so
um in desperation found Dave Ramsey's
method and systematically over the past
12 years have
turned it completely around
so my question is now
that my wife and I have done that we
have two small children we're kind of uh
very very frugal with our money we save
about 90 give or take a month of what we
earn
and uh now we have a different problem
is
learning to live a little bit
um yeah so they're still having a mean
question if you're still living out of a
trauma response brother
yeah I I think it's uh you know just
fear obviously there's a lot of guilt
success guilt and I know this is
um I was a success story with this and
so now we're in this
different stage of
um the recovery and uh it's great and
it's a good problem to have
but uh that you know as other people
experience this and and you know it's
just it's kind of this unknown for me is
how to
give a little yeah did you um
we could probably get sidetracked here
so I'll I'll keep my question pretty
direct did you have a pretty chaotic
childhood
um no I think uh we had a you know my my
parents were in debt uh a lot we had a
you know motorcycles we did my dad kept
us active all the time and so you know
you
it was just kind of we we did certainly
didn't live within our memes
um and uh so that that obviously was
learned by me and then uh you know then
I got into medical school and I got
tremendous amount of debt and it was
really every day I was waking up with
mounting debt and the interest climbing
and so it was in 2011 I just had that
massive realization that you know I I
need to change something I need to have
have goals are you a physician Nick
yeah all right so my academic research
my nerd work was
simply put I studied people who other
people in the community go to for help
and care
okay I studied the mental health of
attorneys and medical personnel and
pastors folks that other people go to
and what I would tell you is yeah you
had a big debt issue
but my guess is you have a broader issue
because what and you know this
pathologically speaking and I want to
not get too nerdy for our audience here
but
if you've got a body responding to
trauma if you've got a body that is
living in an anxious ecosystem the
moment you knock off anxiety one your
brain just moves on to anxiety too into
three
so your body was telling you
probably we owe a lot of money we
haven't slept in a long time I'm
suddenly being in charge of keeping
people alive or well I'm trying to
navigate a family I'm trying to navigate
a crazy uh political ecosystem all those
things happening all at the same time
and so the alarm system that spins up
your body it's almost like throwing
darts and it says it's the money and
then you live like a maniac because
you're Nick and you can and you'll pay
this thing off and without addressing
that core
anxiety almost almost ocpd you get
underneath all that and then your body
just moves on to the next one so now the
problem is you've left your community
behind you've become one of them Nick
and then you you don't have to have joy
in your life and then once you start
having fun it's just going to move on to
the next until you deal with that uh
that lower level
identity shift which is we weren't safe
we are now
and that is a different conversation
than can you give us a three-step plan
to go have more fun do you see what I'm
saying this is about creating a
non-anxious home for Nick and his wife
and his kids
and that will make you better you're on
point there uh everything you said just
it's it's very true
so so what I've seen professionally and
um just walking alongside people is the
further upriver you can get to create
here's the fun exercise you and your
wife go out for a half day retreat
and you all get to do something that
probably never happened in either of
your homes which is you'll get to plan
and dream about the future
y'all cross this Finish Line you survive
you paid off all your debt you got
everything right sized in your home and
now y'all are playing pickleball for the
first time you've never played this game
you don't know the rules and so you'll
have to practice y'all got to figure
this thing out and so
what kind of home what do we want it to
feel like when when you walk home honey
here's what I want to feel like when I
walk in the front door how can we create
this home that is warm or that is funny
or that is joyful and we're going to
reverse engineer that and begin to come
up with this home this non-anxious life
she might look at you like my wife did
me and say I want you to stop working so
much or I want you to love us as least
as much as your clients or patients or
the folks that you are coaching and that
was hard for me and I asked her like
here's what I need and here's what I
want and we address that stuff and dude
I'm telling you the anxiety alarms they
melted along the way
and having joy and having fun and
creating a date night and making okay
we're gonna have to spend x amount of
dollars because 90 is mathematically
insane so let's back it down to 70 and
we are going to practice spending this
20 we're going to go on a date and we're
gonna buy a real nice meal and we're
gonna feel uncomfortable about it and
we're both gonna call it out with a
smile on her face I feel uncomfortable I
feel uncomfortable I feel guilty I feel
guilty and maybe we tip the waitress a
hundred bucks on a hundred dollar meal
just because we can but we're going to
begin to feel that and own it and
metabolize it so that we can transition
to this new identity which is a couple
that's not running for our lives and a
couple that's not anxious all the time
but we are a couple who is living
peacefully into the future
how does that sound
man that is awesome it's uh my dream so
well I really appreciate your time now
you guys yeah I mean
here's the magic words go out on a
retreat and create a new identity for
Nick's home who are we honey who do we
want to be who do we get to be now the
second thing is I want you to be highly
intentional about setting a certain
aside a certain amount of money a month
to give away
and I want you to see that gift I want
you to see the eyes light up when you
give that money away don't just write
checks and and send them via email and
the third thing is I want you to set
aside some money that y'all gonna
practice spending on yourselves and hang
on the line I want to get your address
I've got a new book coming out in
October called building a non-anxious
life and I'm going to send you the first
copy that I get I'm going to mail it to
you as my gift when it comes in
um dude you got exciting things ahead of
you man I'm proud of the work you are
doing to change your family tree my
brother we'll be right back
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
your FPU class I did yes I am done how'd
it go and it was great we had a great
class it was really fun
um walking through the nine lessons with
yeah a few hundred people and it was uh
exciting to see people's progress
already it's amazing within just even a
few short weeks
people on the plan and doing it and it's
great we just uh finished week seven of
the class I'm leading and somebody just
did a debt free scream and it was super
fun that's great so listen all of you
who listen to this show all the time
um
you can you can get the the bits and
pieces and nuts and bolts on this show
for free and you can work it out on your
own you can absolutely do that but what
we've learned over time
is that doing this together with a group
having some accountability people to
walk alongside you people to call or
text and ask questions having a a guy
that leads you through this thing Yoda
Style
it adds so much value and more
importantly you're more likely to stick
with it and there's something about
being around a group of people that you
know are going to ask you how's your
budget how's things going how's this
how's that so listen a proven way to
change your behavior with money is
taking a Financial Peace University
class
it's the difference of like you've tried
to get in shape your whole life and for
many of you that's hard me too it's much
easier when I pay somebody to that is
going to hold me accountable and I go
get a trainer and we figure this thing
out together listen this class has
worked for a million it's Millions it's
nine weeks and you're never gonna handle
money the same way again so listen don't
just listen to the show
join an FPU class at ramseysolutions.com
FPU it's ramseysolutions.com
FPU all right let's go out to Joseph in
Orlando what's up Joseph
not a whole lot how you guys doing today
good good good what's up what well just
uh I'll try to keep the question as
brief as I can I was instructed to do so
so if I um if let's say hypothetically I
saved the amount of mutual funds uh to
pay off my home could I I mean would you
recommend that I draw out everything I
have in my mutual funds to pay off my
home if I save up that amount yes
non-retirement
mutual funds correct not like not yet no
401ks Roth IRAs nothing like that but if
it's just in standard gross type mutual
funds then yes I would I would
concentrate putting as much cash as I
could to get that home paid off because
um because what we find Joseph is not
only mathematically does that just free
up a mortgage and you can throw that
much more back into the market and
you'll build it back up really quickly
but you have paid for real estates
there's no risk in your life and John
you talk about this a lot but when you
don't have debt even a mortgage it's
like you're there's there's no risk
there's nobody that I owe it's like this
true autonomy that you're living this
life that is all yours that you have no
payments so there's something powerful
in that so if I had the amount of money
to pay off my house in non-retirement I
would I would do it today what's your
hang up man
well I don't have it saved up I was just
kind of planning for the future I can
give a little bit of my background if
you'd like sure
so my wife and I we make a combine two
hundred thousand dollars a year uh we
don't have any debts except the mortgage
we have uh right now about 330
000 left in the mortgage uh we put 15
towards uh retirement and that actually
leads to another question so 15 we
divide that up between Roth IRAs 401K we
have the match for that and then the
mutual funds now does the 15 need to go
just towards the Roth IRAs in the 401K
yeah it's response included in that no
just retirements yep because because all
of yeah all of those Roth IRAs and even
your 401k all those retirement Vehicles
is you know you you get so many tax
benefits from that so focusing your
money on that that 15 that anything
above that once the house is paid off
can just go yeah into the market in
mutual funds
okay gotcha
um yeah did you all have any follow-up
questions for me anything I need to
clarify at all no that's it I I the
thing I think it's important to
reiterate is
um
I know folks who are still who bought a
house in 2021 and they have a a
2.25 APR I know people who have a five
or a four or whatever and they're trying
to hedge this and move this around I
Can't Describe to you
the feeling you get when it your boss
tells you to do something and you think
to yourself I don't have to do that
or when an air conditioner breaks in the
biggest fight in your house is who has
to make that phone call not what Bill
you're not going to pay
and it's hard to express it until you've
experienced it but not having a house
payment and having a home
suddenly it turns the news into a
cartoon not a death sentence it becomes
so silly you quit watching it it just
changes everything in your life so
um yeah dude pay that house off
regardless of your interest rate get
that sucker paid off man
all right our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services don't wait till the AC
or something else goes out neighborly
helps you find local providers like air
serve or Mr Appliance or dryer vent
Wizard and Mr Handyman go to
neighborly.com today today's question
comes from Jennifer in North Carolina
we'd love to hear your tips on a budget
Disney trip is it even possible we went
last year for my daughter's fifth
birthday and went all out we stayed on
Disney property went to several
character restaurants and did all the
things and it roughly it cost us roughly
twelve thousand dollars I want to take
our other daughter for her fifth
birthday in October and need to figure
out what how to do it cheaper
I think you and I are gonna have very
different answers on this to Disney I'm
like let me just say this and then
Rachel you answer
um when Hank was four uh my wife was T
it was teaching at a school in Sao Paulo
Brazil right outside of Sao Paulo so we
went we tagged along Hank and I had this
magic trip we picked um avocados and
mangoes off of trees two cans were
flying around it was we wrote a donkey
into the jungle it was amazing it's like
Disney he remembers none of it yes it is
not a core memory I'm sure like romance
I mean not romance but like I'm sure
like good time with Dad I'm sure that's
in there somewhere
not the trip none of it totally none of
it totally so my fifth grade birthday
would be like water balloons fifth no
five-year-old I mean five-year-old
they'll tell that story at your funeral
not the one where mom spent twelve
thousand dollars it was a hyper Maniac
that's just me I know that Rachel you're
a Disney person and I'm not I do like
Disney and if you have the money to do
it that's what you're choosing to go on
vacation knowing that they're not gonna
remember it but you still go because
it's fun and there's still magic at that
age then do it right like that sure why
not if you have to pay me I'll come to
your house for 300 dressed like Goofy
and like I don't know so anyways is
there a cheaper way to do it yes you
guys went all out don't stay on Disney
property get an Airbnb off property uh
don't eat the food bring your own snacks
I mean there's a way to like cut it but
Disney is expensive even just the passes
like you can't get around some of the
costs like it is what it is so I love
how you just said this Rachel just don't
stay there don't eat there don't smile
there go to the park don't go to the
bathroom there and you'll have a great
time the Disney prop well there's tears
at the Disney property so you can do
definitely there's the Haves and
have-nots well there's there's different
ways to do it so again Jennifer I don't
know your situation if you guys I don't
know you got two million dollars in a
Vanguard account like what do we do go
spend 12 grand these are fine the
greatest parenting advice I ever heard
in my life was from Jack Jack Black the
musician comedian here's what he said
and it has changed my parenting all the
graduate classes I ever took it's Jack
Black and here's the advice
don't ever try to make a happy kid
happier
because you're going to see your kids
sitting outside in some mud with a stick
and you're going to think not my kid and
then three hours later you're gonna have
a kid that's over screened full of sugar
full of plastic broken toys and Legos in
their hair and in their ears and all
over whatever
and the kid was loving life in a puddle
of Mud with a stick totally yeah I mean
this is not about
to have a level of like sanity about
yourself
agree to disagree agree to disagree
hey cash just pay cash that's my only
thing and don't expect things or trips
or all of that to change who your kid is
or try to buy their love like that's a
whole different conversation get her a
trampoline it'll be the greatest
birthday ever you want to put that on
Jennifer
judger judging hey this is the Ramsey
Show we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
food
hey welcome back to the Ramsey Show Hey
listen let's clear something up real
quick if you listen to the show for like
10 seconds you know that we hate debt
and some people just don't get that they
think you need debt and credit cards
ah Rachel this gives me the hemorrhoids
they think that they have to have credit
cards so they can do everything else in
life right like buy a car buy a house
none of that is true you think you need
a good credit score to buy a house that
is false listen if I gave you a million
dollars in cash right now that would not
change your credit score because credit
score is nothing to do with how wealthy
you are it has to do with your love
relationship your ooey gooey
relationship with debt that's what a
credit score is the truth is if you're
living a debt-free lifestyle
eventually you're not going to have a
credit score because you don't deal with
debt so when you're ready to buy a house
you got to find a good lender like
Churchill Mortgage who can do what's
called a manual underwriting George
Campbell talks about alt he got one no
credit score got a house so when someone
says you gotta have a credit cards you
don't it's not true and this sounds nuts
but the best plan for your future is to
avoid debt save a big down payment and
get a real estate agent who will help
you find a house you can actually afford
we recommend agents who are Ramsey
trusted meaning their top performers
they're gangsters with years of
experience helping people do home buying
the right way this is not impossible and
I know if you're sitting there you're a
teacher you're a policeman you're
looking at how much money you're not
making this feels impossible it's not
but we want your house to be a blessing
not a nightmare you can find a real
estate agent who will help you do all
these things help you walk through the
process with no credit score
buy the right house for you
with Ramsay Solutions like a trusted
stamp on their soul go to
ramseysolutions.com agent that's
ramsaysolutions.com
agent all right let's go out to Sonia in
Indianapolis what's up Sonia how we
doing
I'm doing great how are y'all I mean I
can't think of a situation where we
would be doing better that's awesome how
are you
doing great and I have a question all
right I want to say thank you to the
Ramsey team you are changing lives of
both myself and my son
um currently
we are in the early stages of baby step
two
my question revolves around purchasing a
van to go live down by the river
I've been for real sounds like we got
Bill Shakespeare on the line what's so I
know where does this uh where does this
idea come from
uh right after the pandemic started I
did purchase a van and I did a build out
on it did a lot of traveling while
working a desk job and it was wonderful
and I would like to do that again and
purchase another vehicle
but I thought the virtual flap from Dave
when I decided that that would be step
3B versus making a down payment on a
house
so I need to have some advice from you
on where in 456 you would place this
purchase and what type of margin I
should be putting against it versus
investing
okay so I just want to clarify though
that you will you will have a primary
residence this is just yeah this is the
residence this is the residence yeah
that was the virtual slop that I got
from Dave
um I did want to purchase the van before
or purchasing fix and Bricks
but after doing some research I do see
the value
of making a home purchase so that is now
in the financial plan and goal set so
you'll do that first and then you're
asking about the van
and then I'm asking about the van
what does the van get you like is it
gets you Freedom does it get you
um flexibility what is that are you just
like camping a lot well the van um I
work remote
so the van will bring me the opportunity
to travel and see the country I do have
friends and family scattered all over
the United States that I did frequent it
also is an opportunity for me to explore
other cities
eventually I would like to relocate out
of my geographical area
okay and I'd like the research behind
that so it's a it's a recreation it's a
toy basically yeah
um yeah okay yeah that's great or do you
have family Sonia are you married kids
no I'm single I have four children
they're all adults okay okay that's
great so Rachel stop me if I'm wrong
here Sonia if you said for 36 months for
three years I'm going to go see the
country and I'm going to live this way
and I'm gonna do all this with cash I I
wouldn't necessarily have a problem with
it
awesome and you said I want to move to a
new town I want to explore some cities
that I might want to relocate in and
live permanently like that I mean Rachel
tell me I'm wrong that that doesn't I
don't think you have to have a house and
then go do that
what we don't want you to do is to look
up and be 55 years old or 60 years old
and you've got no equity you've got no
place
like no pun intended to park and say
this is this is my home all you have is
a completely depreciated out van with
500 000 miles on it that's what we want
to avoid yeah so how old are you Sonia
I turned 50 last September woke up and
decided I don't want to have to work
into retirement and I don't have the
financial footing to avoid that right
now so and where are you at and the baby
steps did you say
what was that where are you at in the
baby steps are you baby step two still
paying off debt
I'm paying off debt my debt-free date
will be essentially Christmas this year
oh good congratulations okay so yeah so
I think my goals would be and where are
you living now
I'm currently in the Upper Midwest I
mean like like uh look like are you at
home you're renting okay perfect no
you're great you're great
okay yeah so Sonya I think mine would be
yeah get to Christmas pay off that debt
uh look to get that emergency fund and
maybe step three and then I would look
to purchase yes some type of real estate
I think that will be really wise
um and to have that to your name to
John's points and again it can be
a town home it could be a condo it
doesn't have to be anything big and
fancy but that there's something a place
to go to that you have
and then I would be focused on
retirement then after that because I
want you to be able to retire right and
actually have money to live off of so
starting that process and then once
that's going
um and again you're you're 50 years old
so you know there can be some ketchup
retirement that you can do when it gets
to that point but again run those
numbers I want that to be a priority for
you
um and then at the same time you can be
saving simultaneously then for a
purchase of a van you know and in the
meantime Sonia I mean you know While
You're expect not while you're getting
out of debt not emergency fund but
beyond that I would be okay while you're
saving up
um for a down payment to rent something
for two weeks if you want you know what
I mean like you can still enjoy your
life after baby step three
um but I I would
focus on though saving up a down payment
because by that time frame
you're going to be two years probably
from now and I want you to be able to
know kind of like you're saying where
you want to be where you want to settle
and and start looking for a home
total sense
does it give you peace or does that give
you angst
um a little of both to be honest
um you know after realizing where I was
and I'll just gonna quote it as drinking
the Kool-Aid of Dave Ramsey I got really
scared and got very serious I took on a
second job good for you about 80 hours a
week how much do you make a year Sonia
my core job is 75k and my side hustle is
about 35 000. wow yeah good for you so
can I tell you something hard to hear
yeah
um and this is like the worst part of my
job is like the
the bearer of reality okay
my guess is looking back you've been
through the mill huh you've been through
it um I've been yeah married in divorce
three times every type of Life situation
has hit so you've been through it
and you've reached a point where you
have some sort of equilibrium and for
the first time possibly ever you've got
peace
and I'm going to tell you I would wait
24 months maybe even 36 months before I
started doing a ton of traveling I would
love to see you just buckle down until
you're 53 years old and make a hundred
thousand dollars on top of a hundred
thousand dollars on top of a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars and get some
Financial margin in your life before you
hit the road and visit friends and
travel
you've been through hell and back and
you've got to give yourself a cushion a
cushion Foundation under you never had
yeah so I would hold off on traveling I
would start sucking away money and then
you're going to be able to have a Freer
55 and 60.
[Music]
foreign
scripture of the day is Philippians 1 6
for I'm confident of this very thing
that he who began a good work in you
will perfect it until the day of Christ
Jesus
Tupac Shakur says happy are those who
dream dreams and are ready to pay the
price to make them come true yes I love
it Rachel is a huge Tupac fan I love
Tupac I do too actually isn't there like
a big conspiracy that he's still
around
um if you want to call Stone Cold Truth
a conspiracy then yes
for sure I knew it he shares a duplex
with Elvis it's incred they're awesome
yeah there's like a group of them
somewhere no for sure if if they if like
Tupac resurfaced I wouldn't think that's
weird at all yeah yeah he he just needed
out yeah I get it
we're gonna get in trouble we understand
yes I I don't I don't let's go out to
Amy in uh Dallas in the in the 817
what's up Amy
Hi how are you guys trying to not get
canceled what are you up to how do you
know area codes John how do I yes I just
love area codes eight one is that yours
really are you two and four eight one
seven stop it
which one are you Amy
area what area code Are you eight one
seven two one four
yes there you go wow okay sorry I just
had to just had to confirm that all
right Amy how come what's up
um okay so my husband and I have 41 500
in debt
um 13 of that 13 000 is in card debt 13
in school loan and then 15 would be in
uh credit cards so my question is should
we trade in our vehicle we only have one
um it's worth 21
000 so we have like 8 000 left if we pay
off the rest that we owe
um so should we do that or should we
just keep on paying it off
how much do you guys make a year
um 95.
um
I mean our rule of thumb really is if
you can pay off the car in 18 months
then it's not like the major problem of
the equation yeah I wouldn't so I
probably just paid off
okay how'd y'all run up thirteen
thousand dollars in credit card bills
it's actually 15.
um we went to Mexico in August and
we got engaged and right after that we
got married and so then we moved into
apartment and we bought we bought stuff
for the apartment that we shouldn't have
so it's a mix of all of that together
yes yes so you guys had like a whirlwind
where you basically upped your debt by
33 well well done Caleb
okay but we learned a lesson right
yes definitely
your question Amy Amy yeah I would I
mean I think you guys can buckle down
and get some extra side hustles and and
pay the debt off I mean I would work at
yeah paying off the car student loans
and then the credit cards
um
and for you guys y'all just got married
yes that's awesome so how did you guys
find Ramsay
um well I've actually been listening to
you guys for a while but never really
like got into it until we got married
but I didn't
um talk to my husband about it until
like February okay um so he was kind of
like iffy but then we started watching
more videos together so March was our
first month of financial peace
okay have you guys gone through
Financial Peace University
yes oh good that's amazing I was gonna
wedding gift that's you okay a wedding
gift my book know yourself know your
money Josh oh Josh John do you want man
you were co-host of the year
give Amy away
nothing says I love you like here have
my book Kayla jeez Rachel her name is
I'm sorry Amy geez this whole segment's
falling apart here Amy
listen Josh get it together
I'll take that sorry Rhonda
um Amy so listen are y'all working side
hustles and uh grinding on the side here
to get this thing done
we're not at the moment but that's what
I want to see you do because when I look
at it one time so I'm gonna definitely
um try to look for another job to have
it be full time do you guys have kids
no not yet okay so when I see 13 13 and
15 that's pretty spread out like that
that says to me y'all are the problem
globally like there's not one big cancer
there this is just a life that you all
have chosen to live and now you've
chosen a different path I would love to
see you all get one two and three extra
jobs and really really get after it for
the next 12 months because you're gonna
open your eyes and you're gonna be
stunned at how far y'all move this
needle because honestly Amy I'm like
your numbers I mean if you guys lived
again you guys are renting an apartment
if you didn't live the Dallas life like
you guys lived on nothing
and you guys can get this knocked out in
12 months yeah and like Dallas is
expensive but if y'all don't get a
knucklehead apartment there you can make
this thing happen are you in that's just
a question are you in
yes definitely all right I'm excited for
you I'm gonna give you Josh delony's new
book uh own your pass change your feet
I'm gonna give you my book too we'll
give you both mine and Rachel's and
we're gonna send you um a year of every
dollar the the Uber app that's you can
connect with your bank so you and your
husband can y'all can learn this new
money path together in real time
um hey and if you want to get some side
gigs you need some extra cash but you
don't have time for one passive income
might be for you get the ends of and
outs of what passive income is and how
to get started go to ramseysolutions.com
newsletter and you can get some other
ideas for making some money on the side
um let's run out to Kayla real quick in
Billings before the show's over or right
up against the clock Kayla um get right
to your question
um hey
the question is um how to go about when
you have health issues and health debt
um the health debt that kind of keeps
coming Keeps Us in
of essentially no money
um and we are both working quite a bit
of hours and I have two jobs and I make
a good income but it's just not enough
to keep up with the medical bills that
are going to keep coming um what are the
challenges
um
it's been in five years I
said I didn't work for a while
um issues that they just aren't sure
they just label it inflammation but they
don't know
um now I have debt from you know
Insurance not always covering it but I
have ongoing appointments that helped
keep it at Bay I guess but not really
solve the problem
but we're kind of on E every month and
it's you know stressful because it's in
my it doesn't seem to be ending so
so you don't know here's the
my career has been spent walking into
gnarly situations and having the honor
but also the hard task of just telling
somebody the Stone Cold Truth is that
okay
yeah please so you have a chronic
ongoing
medical condition whether that's cancer
whether that's infertility treatments
that people
um are going through whether that's
chronic inflammation that you just can't
get to the bottom of try to figure it
out figure it out whatever it may be
maybe special needs whatever's going on
mental health challenges
there's a moment when you have to make
peace with reality this is going to be
recurring in part of our life
and it's from sitting in that reality
and sometimes you have to grieve what we
hoped and wished was going to happen in
our life because it's not going to
happen and we have a different picture
and that's okay which is making peace
with this is going to be different and
making peace doesn't mean it's all going
to be roses and joy and fun and ah
Making Peace sometimes is just throwing
your hands up and saying this is
and from that moment you and your
husband can begin to have some hard
conversations about
well where do we live because maybe
Billings Montana is really expensive
um maybe we always had dreams of living
on 20 acres out here in Billings that's
not going to happen we got to move
somewhere where we can get great medical
care but we can also live at a reduced
rate what job do you have versus what I
have those are the only reality toggles
those are the only switches you can
toggle right because the other constant
is you're gonna have some medical
challenges at least for the foreseeable
future none of this is fun none of this
is exciting or what we wanted to happen
but it is and I think that's the place
where you start and maybe you and your
husband land right back where you are
and we're just going to live on E for
for the foreseeable future that's great
that's great at least y'all both make
peace with that
um it's the constant frustration that
you keep showing up and empty showing up
on empty showing up on empty that's
going to drive you all mad so let's own
where we are let's own this reality and
then let's begin to make a plan that's
going to look different than we dreamed
but it's going to be the one that's
going to give us a non-anxious life
moving forward hey thank thanks
everybody for listening thanks you to
the good folks in the booth thank you to
Rhonda Cruz my co-host John Josh Delaney
you're wonderful thank you America we'll
see you soon right here on the Ramsay
show
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]